[Music]
all right right now it seems the wait is
over and hearing from Roseann a week's
ever rotated by fire and her show got
canceled she is sitting down for an
in-depth interview Thursday night 9:00
p.m. Eastern Roseanne Barr will speak
out and join us for an exclusive
interview he has learned that interview
will be pre taped inside Sean Kennedy's
Manhattan studio tomorrow leading up to
the broadcast Roseanne is then scheduled
to be on the Upper West Side at 8 p.m.
for an appearance with her friend
Rabbi Shmuley botella tickets cost $25
to see what he's taunting as their quote
calm conversation yesterday on shmoo
Lee's podcast he asked her about this
disturbing YouTube brand keep writing
romance races please after two months of
me explaining of course I'm going to
scream at some point and I did I lost my
cool I was so angry today the target of
that vulgar explosion President Obama's
former advisor at Valerie Jarrett
appeared on the view ABC meanwhile
announced their rebranded spin-off the
Connors will make its network from the
air on October the 16th Roseanne says
she is focused on producing her own
youtube talk-show series called the
Roseanne show I can say anything I want
to say and I can't get fired which is a
great that's great
you
[Music]